hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q and a section i realize i've
left my hat in the background it was
drying from yesterday's kayak
all right yes oh and there's a cat next
to it well that's wonderful
all right so we're going to answer your
super chat questions starting with ones
from the previous hour and at some point
in the middle we will migrate to
questions from this hour actually we're
going to start as we have been
with a few from episode 40. starting
with just a couple of comments that i
found particularly nice
and then a couple of questions and then
we'll go
to those from the last hour greetings
from denmark
you guys provide a litmus test for the
information we get ever since we got 24
7 news and after 9 11 we have slowly
been divided to a point where even a
family dinner feels like walking a
minefield
so thank you for that and the second
comment is
your discord is my new social media just
voting with my dollar here
call it a paid review by me worth the
buy-in awesome
thank you for that as well this is
one of two questions uh then that i will
that we will address from episode 40
that we didn't get to last time
in what way are you progressive you guys
seem very liberal what are some
progressive policies you want what is
your ideal progressive
leadership well that's a tough one
i have to say um as much as people swear
that the distinctions between
leftist liberal progressive
uh are clear i've never understood them
as somebody who's been on the left
all my life i certainly remember a point
where the term liberal had been
stigmatized so badly that i started
referring to myself as a progressive
just simply to
not have the conversation bogged down
immediately so at least at that point
i think the distinction was an aesthetic
one at best
i would say the thing about
the thing that causes me to say that i'm
a progressive
is that i believe we have to change we
have to make a kind of progress
in order to survive that our system is
on a fatal trajectory
short term that it contains many of the
right elements but that we have to
introduce some new structure and that
basically the founders didn't know about
for example
evolution and so they didn't build a
system that was robust to the evolution
of let's say mechanisms of capture
so i would just say i derive the
meaning of the word progressive from the
fact that we need progress i believe
that progress is essential
but i don't believe almost any of the
things that many who would call
themselves
progressive claim to want or say that we
need
so i believe we have to make progress
but that's about as far
as uh that allegiance goes
i wouldn't be surprised to find others
in that movement who had a similar
feeling but in general what the
progressives claim to want is dangerous
yeah i guess i would i would just add
that um
many have noted that we often talk in
terms that sound like
um putting a lot of weight
on individual responsibility and you
know personal responsibility and such
and and we do but that is not
contradicted by also seeing a need
for uh collective action for those
problem
problems and issues in society
that will be gamed by individuals if you
don't have a mechanism
by which you can prevent them being
gamed and so systems like
well like health care
we can do better than what we currently
have the united states
in which you have insurance companies
vying for
the dollars of people without actually
seeing
any increase in the quality of the
health care we're getting
i would just add to these two things
already on the table that
in general i find that liberals
are more likely to see
inequality in the current system that is
worthy of and demanding of a solution
and i do believe our system has many
biases in it that are worthy
of a solution conservatives tend to see
the system as more functional
and ultimately as you've probably heard
us say
or me at least the aim
of a liberal the aim of a progressive
ought to be
to create a society that is so
functional
that one would be a fool to attempt to
change it to make it better
in other words perfection is impossible
a system that works really really well
is something that you should leave
functional and i don't believe we're
there yet i believe we have a long way
to go
um but the goal of everyone should be to
create a society that is so good that
they now want to conserve it thus the
goal of everyone should be turned to be
able to turn
everyone into conservatives not
for a past that that already exists but
for
a future that we would like to create
and then can try to conserve
and i think as has been noted across
many domains now part of what is going
on with this movement
not so much what we see on the streets
although i think there is some element
of that as well but for instance
um on camp in campuses and in
corporations where you have the creation
of a whole
suave this whole divisions devoted to
diversity equity and inclusion these
officers
are these diversity equity inclusion
officers are creating
um a world you know have have inherited
have themselves created a world
that then requires that they never
actually do the job that they're
pretending that they're claiming to be
trying to do
because if they did so they would put
themselves out of work and so
you know what what we should all be
doing is you know those of us
who you know have jobs that are specific
activists and you know die officers and
such
should if if they are in any way being
honest
about their stated goals and aims they
are
they should be trying to put themselves
out of the particular kind of work that
they are currently doing
so i think this also now that i think
about it creates a taxonomy of
conservatives that i think i had not
uh formalized yet um that there are
three reasons in light of what we've
just said about progressives and
liberals
there are three reasons that you might
find yourself
on the conservative side one of them
is that you believe that the system is
in a place where change is likely to be
more harmful than it is desirable
the second you're not inherently opposed
to the idea of change you just don't
think it's necessary
right and so that's that's what we
should all be shooting for is that state
the second
is that you might be insensitive to
problems that might be solved in the
system in other words you might regard
it as
fairer than it is because maybe you're
not in one of the categories to which it
is routinely unfair
or something like that and the third are
people for whom the system is biased who
might like to conserve those biases
and so i sometimes think that liberals
when they talk about
what they see wrong with conservatives
imagine that it's all that last category
right and it isn't right i i run into
all three of these types and so
anyway i probably worth keeping in mind
that's really good three types of
conservatives
and uh you know one of those types is a
type that even
uh honorable liberals should be aspiring
to join that's right
good what is the evolutionary
explanation of
drug addiction why are there withdrawals
for something that slowly kills you
lovely love you thanks and unity for to
win all right
unity for to win um you want me to start
sure yeah so first of all i should say
that there's an old model of addiction
which i'm convinced has some truth in it
but has been replaced by a new and
better model of addiction so the old
model of addiction
was based on heroin primarily highly
addictive drug
that mimics the molecular structure of
endorphins
and the idea is that your body produces
these molecules
to keep you for example from being
overwhelmed
by um sensation
by pain in particular so you have all of
these systems across your body that are
detecting
damage and pain and they don't
they are you are under sensitive to them
so you are not
for example constantly paying attention
to what's going on on your arms and all
of this so you can pay attention to what
you need to focus on
so these molecules that we make that
limit sensation
are something you can trigger
artificially with a plant-made molecule
a molecule that the plant makes in order
to keep herbivores from eating it
and the thing is your body is monitoring
how many of these molecules you need so
to the extent that you are supplementing
those molecules your body
starts making less and less of them so
if you overwhelm your system
with these molecules maybe you get a
pleasant sensation of
numbness or whatever it is but you're
also
sending a message into the system that
causes a reduced production of your
endogenous molecules
and at the point that you try to remove
the supplement
you don't have enough of these things
since you're suddenly overwhelmed
by the sensations that you were blocking
out and it takes time
right the withdrawal period it takes
time to go back to producing normal
levels of these things so
kicking the habit involves basically a
kind of
dysfunction and so the idea was
it's hard to get off heroin because it's
very painful as a result of this
imbalance and that keeps people who do
heroin doing more heroin
the new model of addiction suggests
uh and there's a great deal of truth in
this too that
creatures all of us tend to make these
bad choices about ingesting these
molecules
when we don't have things that are
rewarding available to us
right and so uh you know a rat in a
boring cage
may press the cocaine lever again and
again but a rat that has entertaining
things to do is much less likely to get
addicted to
whatever substance is on offer and so
you will also recognize that this
mirrors what you see in the world that
people with bad options often do get
addicted to drugs
and this goes to one of my philosophical
principles which is
you shouldn't hold people responsible
for bad decisions when they
only had bad decisions available to them
it's easy to conflate cause and effect
and it's also
quite possible that you have sort of a
uh you know
an exacerbating effect where someone
with bad options was more likely to
become addicted and of course becoming
addicted it reduces their options
further
uh which causes them to be even more
prone to addiction perhaps of
a greater a greater extent or of more
substances etc
totally so um i would say a number of
things
i'm gonna try to make sure we answer the
exact question we were asked i think
that there's a lot
there's a lot in there there's a lot in
what we've said that's relevant to the
the question but you know so basically
you have a physical system that you're
disrupting in some sort of pleasurable
way and the removal of it
leaves a disrupted system which is not
functional
good options defeat bad options
which suggests a that you know the thing
that makes me angriest
about what i was told about drugs when i
was young is that drugs was even a
category
because drugs isn't a category right
drugs are many different substances some
of which you may
you know if you're trying to cope with
certain things these may be absolutely
the most powerful tool in the arsenal
right in the case of things like uh
psilocybin
right it's a very powerful tool i would
say don't
these none of these should be treated
recreationally though you should
potentially have fun in the context of
many of them
but but just i mean you mentioned
psilocybin and that
and other hallucinogens slash entheogens
um psychedelics you know all of these
words mean slightly different but
largely overlapping things
um are interesting in that almost none
of them
actually have physically addicting uh
characteristics
right that you actually uh don't there
there are
no people who are physically addicted or
would experience withdrawal
um from not taking mushrooms anymore uh
they might well miss them
if yeah and especially if it's if it's
someone who
is micro dosing regularly and it's
helping
alleviate anxiety uh for instance
uh they might see a decline in mental
health as a result but
in terms of physical addiction the model
that you laid out bret
for what happens with heroin uh is just
it's just not the same
thing and so this is this is exactly why
we we object
to this idea that you know drugs is a
category that makes
much sense um you know you at least have
to include
um you know caffeine and nicotine in
in the drug category and frankly
caffeine and nicotine
are a much better match for the model
that includes heroin
than are any of the entheogens or
hallucinogens
yeah so um i guess i would just
say finally that basically all of this
argues that there's some sort of
matrix of characteristics that you ought
to be thinking of
before you decide to engage one of these
substances and
you know in the case of heroin probably
just too
freaking dangerous to be worth toying
with it at all
on the other hand that molecule taken in
another another way might be something
that is
manageable right what you don't want to
get into is a situation
in which um the
solution to the degradation of the
function of the molecule is more of the
molecule
or you get into a positive feedback
situation where
in order to deal with the loss of
effectiveness of the molecule you become
addicted to greater and greater amounts
of it or something like that yeah
and that's i mean i think that is an
answer to the question about withdrawal
right like you don't
you don't expect withdrawal uh for
uh for something like mushrooms um
but anything to which your body has
become accustomed and as therefore
uh either down regulated production of
the thing in question
in the case of of heroin and you know
the similar
opiates of the opioids that the body
itself produces
or is otherwise accommodating um
yeah i don't actually have a good model
in my head i want i was going to say
your body is otherwise accommodating for
the intake
and therefore if you start um reducing
it your body's going to go out of whack
but like with alcohol i actually i do
not have a good model for what like
alcohol withdrawal and um
and and such is about i don't have i
haven't seen it
i don't know any close stories and i
don't i don't have a good model of what
that is yeah i mean i think we can say
something general and it's possible that
somebody else
knows the specifics but the body
is capable of applying some kind of
resource so to the extent that alcohol
disrupts your ability
to accomplish something maybe you know
it
numbs your senses uh some part of you
can
ratchet up heightened sensitivity right
it doesn't
yeah negate the effect but it may
compensate for the effect to an extent
yeah it's going to be compensatory
somehow it's going to be compensatory
in some way and it also you know no
doubt
there are just simply costs
to producing the detoxifying
equipment um and so anyway that
uh it may be that withdrawal has to do
with the fact that if you
if you drink a lot very regularly and
then suddenly you're not drinking but
you're ratcheted up
you've got all these molecules that have
no uh
no job no job that may be costly too in
some way
yeah okay let's move on
do you think holidays have an
evolutionary component to them
about every culture has them do you
think a holiday like halloween
might act as a way to teach our children
to control their fear when they see
something scary
so that's that's really two different
questions um and certainly they have an
evolutionary component and if we
if we take it a little bit larger than
holiday and make it
you know an annually or otherwise
reliably repeating celebration of some
sort
um it it acts as a calendar it can act
as a reset
it can act as a you know an often an
actual reset you know like
this is this is where we this is the
moment
um before before which we will forgive
our debts we will forgive
our insults and we will move forward we
apologize for the things that we've done
wrong over the past year
exactly we will speak to our ancestors
and tell them what has happened
and going forward we know that anything
that happens we're gonna have to tell
our ancestors about that next
next year again uh they're you know
these these
are all things that are present in
celebratory uh you know reliable
holidays across many cultures and
almost all of our modern ones in the in
the weird countries and the
western educated industrialized rich
democratic countries
have lost so much of their context that
they've become mostly about markets and
buying [ __ ]
rather than um you know you know
thanksgiving which obviously has its
root
in um some you know not so terrific
um original you know sort of founding
myths of america
however remains one of the one of the
holidays that is least touched by the
market you know other than turkey
farmers there's not a lot of people who
you know explicitly benefit and profit
from from the holiday and it really
tends to be a time
when at least some form of friends or
family come together and share good food
and break bread together and
and hopefully to some degree discuss
some of the things that they are in fact
thankful for
so far so you and i for years have been
tinkering with holidays
feeling that many of them maybe not up
to date and we have
uh in particular modified both hanukkah
and christmas
to modernize them or to
update them in some way i'm wondering if
actually now that you mention it
thanksgiving doesn't need to be modified
too i've been hesitant about
thanksgiving because since it is
effectively the only important holiday
that hasn't been
uh captured by the market captured by uh
yeah
by market forces it seems like don't
touch it
on the other hand i'm wondering if it
doesn't fit a little bit with
the question of unity and why it's
breaking down
right in other words there is some
aspect of thanksgiving which is about
breaking bread
with somebody on the other side of
something yeah and if that could not be
made
if it could not be made into a healing
holiday if
in effect i would say sitting down with
people
across some unbridgeable divide and
breaking bread with them
is inherently positive and it is
inherently american
oh absolutely that's that's wonderful um
to the second part of the question about
halloween i
i've been thinking a lot about halloween
actually which is never
it was never a holiday that i was
particularly into i just you know
cosplay wasn't my thing
and uh so much of what is happening on
the streets is that
right it's it's it's cosplay and
unfortunately a lot of what's happening
in some of the you know some of the
fringe
elements of um you know for instance
trans activism
is actually cosplay as well and um you
know we're not
not allowed to say that but that doesn't
make it any less true
uh and i i think you know halloween
is pretty ridiculous in its american
form but you know
much beloved and you know we encouraged
our children
as long as they wanted to to to do it
although our elder son zach resisted the
the market part of it from a very early
age and we can tell some
stories about that at a different time
perhaps
but i do think that we are missing uh
you know we have
in some parts of the united states
anyway there's some celebration of mardi
gras which is
again just this bastardization of
carnival
and you know carnival is a depending on
where you
are in latin america originating from
you know the combination
of the sort of you know animist
spiritual traditions
of the original people with the
catholicism that came in with the
spaniards and the portuguese
and you have for a few days
before lent is to start before you have
to give up something and basically live
your your best and most pure life for
a lot of time for 40 days i guess um
you get to just party right and so
that's the way that americans understand
you just do a party and you drink and
well that's a ridiculous pasteurization
and i've been
lucky and unlucky enough to be present
for several carnivals
in um in panama and in ecuador on i
guess three different occasions
and some of them have been ridiculous
and some of them have been
amazing and what you see when it works
is exactly what carnival and actually
before
the first time before i knew i was going
to be in all these cases it was with
study abroad classes so i was there with
my students
and before i went down and you know i
hadn't planned for us to be
there for carnival you just find that
when you're traveling for weeks and you
happen to be there during carnival
everything shuts down and there's
nothing else you can do so you just i
thought okay
we'll make it a learning moment we'll
make it a learning few days we're gonna
you know go
in effectively as participant observers
as ethnographers and see what we can
learn and
yes participate and so i went back to my
um
actually my professor at uc santa cruz
who had taught my brazilian society and
culture class when i had been an
undergrad and who would
who had taught me what i knew about
carnival which was entirely at that
point in abstraction
and who himself worked um on the um
on the atlantic coast of of brazil near
the
um exit to i think near the exit of the
amazon near belem
and one of the things that he said that
was most
impactful to me which i then shared with
my students before we went
and experienced this thing firsthand was
that it's an exploration of
liminality it's an exploration of
borders and which borders
um are there and you can touch them and
you can push them and they deform a
little bit but they're always going to
bounce
back and which ones actually can be
reversed and which ones can be reversed
for a day and you can experience life as
the other and you're definitely going to
go back
and so the exam the three examples that
i remember he gave
were male female and um
parent child and employer employee
and i'm sure that last one had um sort
of
slave and owner manifestations in the
past but
you know that's that's not what is going
on now and just being able to
to switch your position you know choose
one of those or some
other dichotomy or not it could be
something with something with more roles
than two
and try on a different mantle for a day
for a few days
and know that at the end of it unless
you are
you know grotesque unless you do
something truly awful you're allowed to
explore space
that you wouldn't otherwise explore and
then you get to go back to your life and
and think on it and learn from it and
and
have a better sense of what the other
people in your life are also living like
all right two things to add to that um
one of them
i have some trepidation about but we'll
go there anyway but
i want to just say that time we were
together in ecuador for
carnival um in cowenka and 2016.
in cuenca in 2016 30 of our students and
we were in two children
for 14 days yeah we were that was the
longest place we were in our 11 week
trip through
ecuador we were in cuenca for 14 days so
this was a place where the students were
all living in their own
states in their own home stays and you
know they knew the town they'd been
walking around it and so carnival
happened and you know we would intersect
with them
walking through the square or anything
but we weren't all together as a
group in the same way 34-person mob
going through carnival
right so anyway it was very interesting
some of them got themselves into some
trouble
and um you know all sorts of stuff
happened but
we were able to observe and participate
uh so in
cuenca and in ecuador more generally one
of the things
that goes on during carnival is that
people buy
this bottled foam and they shoot it at
each other so you know
boys might shoot it at girls that they
are fond of or whatever
but people are spraying uh other people
we got sprayed for being gringos and
that was to stall in keeping with it
um but one of the things i remember um
being struck by was that there was a
police band
oh and you took a beautiful picture yeah
i got a nice picture yeah if i know we
were gonna talk about this i would have
found it but anyway a little girl on
her dad's shoulders looking at a police
brass band marching down and being
covered in foam people are just
attacking the police with this foam
and i was thinking at the time that
actually this was a really
healthy phenomenon the band you know the
police were not freaking out they were
continuing to play
it was all something you know by
stepping in one guy's
trombone maybe it was like filled with
foam even yeah
so anyway imagine how healthy it is to
have that relation that is the opposite
relationship with the police
all cops are bastards right all cops are
bastards you know
to interact with them in any human way
is unacceptable
versus oh you know what there's one day
a year where i'm gonna shoot that cop
that
has been giving me trouble or whatever
shoot him with foam with foam right
exactly so um so that's one thing
the other thing also involves a cop the
dhs officer that i
mentioned on the stream and have taken
so much crap for talking to
how dare you yeah how dare you talk to a
cop but anyway among the many
interesting things he told me
is about the training that he and his
fellow dhs officers had gone through
uh in order to deal with uh riots and
protests and the like
and it involved all kinds of things like
uh enduring
uh tear gassing they you know they had
they were themselves tear-gassed he did
it on multiple occasions
um and there was also some sort of thing
where they
traded off uh basically
playing at being protesters and
uh and all these things and he describes
basically these war games between
dhs officers playing the dhs role and
dhs
officers playing the protesters role and
he
and the goal is not how better to harm
the other
right goal is how to be a better dhs
officer how to be a better policeman
and those better better policemen better
dhs
officer does not mean how can i hurt
other people the most
no in fact in fact the thing that struck
me the most
was that actually a he saw his
role as protective that the thing that
he feared was that he was being boxed
into a situation by protesters in which
violence would be the only way to
protect
the buildings in question and he didn't
want people to get hurt his point was
we're not going to allow them to take
the buildings we can't um
so anyway there was that but also you
know he described
his own how much fun it was to be on the
other side of this line
and you know he basically it was clear
that he was into it and he understood
something
about you know that's not to say that
what is motivating these protesters is
entirely
about fun but there is some aspect of it
in which
they do clearly enjoy their role and
um it was interesting to hear you know i
hear
one side demonizing the other i did not
hear him demonizing the protesters as
troubling as it was to have them uh
launching
ball bearings with slingshots and things
like that right
okay next question is there an
evolutionary explanation
for how something like placebo would
come into existence
is it maybe a side effect of some other
feature that was naturally selected
oh you're going to hate this answer you
just i apologize for it in advance
but that placebo effect that you think
exists it doesn't
there is a placebo effect but it works
like this
if you have a condition in which the
manifestation of the condition is
subjective
like i feel pain or i feel anxiety then
placebos
will actually address it and you will
feel less
anxiety or less pain but this does not
manifest itself
in things like longevity if you have a
condition
that reduces your longevity and you take
a placebo
there is no evidence that supports the
idea that you will live longer
or that you will basically anything
that's objective rather than subjective
does not respond to this and so
um you are absolutely correct in asking
this question that if placebo existed in
the form that people
think it exists that would be an
evolutionary paradox of
major proportions because why is it if
you have the capacity to heal
that you don't just simply heal if
somebody by lying to you about
some treatment they've given you could
trigger an endogenous system for healing
and the endogenous system should
uh trigger itself so anyway i am already
anticipating a
great deal of hate mail that i will get
over this one i will be told that the
placebo effect
does exist and that i will be pointed to
a thousand things that will not reflect
that
and i appreciate all of them let me tell
you um
and uh i don't know i suppose
that's where that's where it lands so
from the point of view of
can you feel better by being told you've
been given some treatment that
um yes you can if it's subjective
and i think the interpretation for why
that would be is somewhat obvious
right in other words how focused on
something subjective like pain should
you be
is a question of what situation you're
in right if you're at home
and you've damaged your limb and you
need not to pick stuff up maybe you need
to be focused on that pain
if you're still on a battlefield maybe
you need to ignore that pain so you can
survive to get home and focus on the
pain
and so we have systems that are
modulatable for this reason
that are subjective uh and the ability
to modulate them
uh makes sense from an evolutionary
perspective
in the spirit of truth seeking can you
brett clarify a statement that you have
made several times
black lives are undervalued by whom
brett are they undervalued specifically
um
by us collectively and i hesitate to say
i think that
includes black people but there is a
degree into which there there is an
almost
um an expectation of
misfortune befalling black people that
has just been
um i think absorbed into
the culture and what it means is that
you know i mean this has been pointed
out in certain contexts like the degree
to which people freak out
when a white woman has disappeared
compared to a black woman i'm not sure
if this has been quantified but there is
a tendency
for society to empathize more in certain
cases than others
and i think it really does have
significant effects you know
a crisis is less of a crisis when it
happens
to a black neighborhood and um you know
that's something we have to address now
i don't think you can address it by
wagging your finger at people that's not
going to work
we can address it structurally and you
know i find myself in a very different
position
than many of the people in our social
circle
um with respect to things like you know
do we need
you know black focused hero narratives
right i actually think we probably do
and i've gotten some pushback from
black people on this right that's a
concession i shouldn't make but
i really believe it it doesn't mean that
you can't empathize with a character
that doesn't look like you i think you
can and i
hope that we will all do that trick um
you know i certainly empathize with
female characters
and i empathize with black characters
but to the extent
that for especially for younger kids
that there might be
some tendency to more easily project
yourself into
the role of somebody who in some
superficial way looks like you
i think it would be healthy and the
great thing would be
that we get society to a place where
those superficial characters
characteristics matter so little that
all of these narratives become available
to all of us
right and that the the really important
thing is
uh well suffice it to say it should be
about the content of their character
rather than the color of the skin of the
protagonists i mean
i think i think you're demonstrably
right that the younger the child the
more suggestible they are
and if they only see narratives
of of people being heroic who don't look
like them
it it might be a conclusion that at
least some of those children
come to um that they therefore you know
aren't
aren't made of the right stuff to become
heroic what we see
a hundred percent is this recognition
being gamed
and i don't know that it is being gamed
racially i hope not i don't even
actually know what that would look like
although i'm
sure we'll hear from people who can
point me to some examples but it's a
hundred percent being gained by the
by the trans rights activists and um the
idea
that you put in front of little children
the idea that they
are maybe you know maybe maybe not the
sex that their parents say they are
when in fact we know this to be an
incredibly rare condition
that is not created by reading a book or
from
wanting to cosplay as a kid or wanting
to play around with gender norms because
that's in part what childhood and
adolescence is about
this this in part this successful gaming
of
um of narrative and playing on the
suggestibility of young children and the
gullibility of parents is part of why we
are in
the bad position we're in right now with
the rise of
so-called trans people among teenagers
i also wonder if um marketing culture
has exacerbated something terribly and
that
basically because marketers profit by
making people insecure about something
that they then
can be sold a solution to that we have
been sold archetypes that are far
narrower than they might otherwise be
and in fact yeah women
when it played sorry but it plays too on
um the insecurity of parents i mean if
for people who aren't parents you won't
necessarily know this
um parents are expected to be
uncomfortable and unsure about what
they're doing
in in modern culture and those of us who
are like well no we don't necessarily
know what we're doing but let's figure
it out as we go along
and let's not look to authority for
answers but try to deduce from observing
our children and ourselves and what
works and what doesn't um how best to
to interact and always do so with love
we found ourselves rare among parents
who we interacted with
in not feeling it necessary to
look for authoritative sources on how it
was that we were supposed to be doing
what we're doing
and given given that and given that you
know the market is everywhere
and um it is bullying people into
suggesting that they have no idea what
they're doing and they really need to do
something different and they need to buy
this in order to fix the problem that
there's that they're causing
um that i think actually it's not just
the suggestibility of little children
but the gullibility of the parents who
are buying these products
because they're being told by some
number of forces some of which are
not good at all that if they do not
affirm their child's gender identity for
instance right this very moment that
they are being bad parents
well that's that's gaming appearance not
just destroying children and obviously
the destruction of children is far more
important but hey parents
try not to be gamed if there's some
chance that this is going to cost you
some money to be gamed
uh there's a there's a good chance that
that's what's going on being gamed
yeah absolutely um yeah
and many people are trying to sell you
one wrong idea or another for various
different reasons
you know in the case of marketers it's
the most obvious um
but they're all kinds of bad ideologies
with respect to
to parenting that have been floated i
was just going to add that when when we
have traveled especially
latin america is the place where i've
been most systematic about this
but i have frequently gone into the
cosmetic section of supermarkets
and i don't know if i've discussed this
before publicly but um the wall of
for example um hair care products
you know or baby products too
they represent an archetype of what
people should look like and it's
far it's definitely latinized
but it is very light-skinned
it is very often a blonde white woman
right well
no i see more it's it's
latinas but very very
light-skinned leaning very much towards
the
the north american aesthetic
which is itself being pushed by
an advertising industry that obviously
is using
dissatisfaction to to sell people's
stuff
but anyway the difference you know the
supermarket's a great place because
you're right there with the actual
people
and you're right there with the image
that they're being sold
and the two are not a match and anyway
it's very striking once you
tune into it because at home we don't we
ignore
what's on the shelf we try to because
it's an attack on us yep
it's it's something that we learn to
ignore but tuning back in is very useful
i mean this actually this this will be
totally not obvious to people who
um to most people that um one of the
things that we find
value in in travel is precisely
spending time when we're not deep in
nature when we're actually in a in a
town
exploring like sure we explore the
you know the churches and the museums
and you know and whatever it is that and
you know hang out in the squares and
eat the local food and you know see if
we can talk to local people but
also going into hardware stores and
going into markets
and just spending time in the space with
the local people are buying the things
that they need to do the stuff of their
lives
from a hardware store you can figure out
what kinds of problems they're having to
solve
and you know in in we started doing this
when we were both doing graduate work
um in would have been costa rica and
panama and so
you know i would find myself going into
a hardware store because i really needed
a bunch of netting and you know chords
and like okay how am i going to make
this big enclosure that i have to make
uh with what's here
and so it was driven by my desire to
solve a problem but
you you learned a tremendous amount
about what problems were being solved by
the local people as well
and you know because because it's never
it's not a home depot or a low it's
probably i mean it is in the big cities
down there at this point but
you know the local hardware store tells
you something just like you know the
local feed store
in a small u.s town will tell you
something about the
the local economy and the local people
and local culture in a way that the lows
at the you know city 30 miles up the
road won't yeah
absolutely and if you're in a very hot
place where you can't escape the heat
you can also go into a supermarket and
pretend to be buying cheese which is
something i'm not
proud that we've done we did that in
venice last year actually
it was hot it was really hot it was hot
and the cheap sometimes you just have to
actually open the cheese case in order
to
figure out if you want cheese that's a
bridge too far but um
but pretending to buy cheese is uh it's
well within your right as a
north american i see okay
um imagine sometime
within the next year you stumble across
your ideal website for consuming general
news are there any characteristics in
its content or structure that come to
mind that would make it stand out to you
yeah i mean i think you're you're
getting such a large dose of this if
you're a fan of this channel that
um this will not come as news but i mean
actually you know the way to do it is
yeah i don't actually know i feel like i
have lots of answers and none of them
are
pithy enough here's the thing we were
popular as professors you were
top level popular um for various reasons
right one of them had to do with the
fact that we actually
leveled with our students which meant
that there were several things that were
unusual in other
contexts that our students found with us
one was
we told them things that were
uncomfortable
and then we helped them sort through it
also
when we were wrong we told them we had
been wrong
and so a news channel that pretends to
be
um just simply accurate at a factual
level
and does not behave properly in the case
that it is revealed to be otherwise
is obviously a dangerous structure so
i would just say a newscast that was
honest about what it didn't know right
that was
honest about the fact that there are
biases
that impact coverage no matter what you
do right it's not like there is an
objective way to report
stories but being honest about
perspective
and um tracking i think maybe the most
important thing
would be how well did the
viewpoint and the report stand up to
what followed
right was it borne out by what followed
or not so the predictive capacity of the
approach
is important yeah and for some reason as
you were talking
what came to mind was a class that
had ended before we showed up but when
we started graduate school
at the university of michigan we were
told that there had been a long-standing
course
taught by correct me if i'm wrong don
tinkel and dick alexander
i think dick alexander who was your
major phd advisor and he was on my
committee
and don tinkle was was dead by the time
that we were there
um and this to people who aren't in uh
sort of organismal biology space this
will seem like how different could they
possibly be
but the two of them taught this course
in which dick was basically the
evolutionist
and don was the ecologist and they went
at each other because very often
evolutionary approaches to questions and
ecological approaches to questions
um are dissimilar enough um they that
they just
like ships passing in the night they
can't even see each other they can't
even
see that they're addressing the same
question in some cases
and so this class which had run for
many years at the graduate level at
michigan was apparently
incredibly powerful also incredibly
popular
but incredibly powerful precisely
because because it had two people
who were both giants in their field who
like really were excellent scientists
and also had great personal respect for
one another and also
really deeply disagreed with a lot of
what the other person had to say
and so i mean that was one of the things
that that we also did that was
successful in the classroom that we
would disagree
and yet we like it was clear we were
married and we appeared to be happily
married and so
you know we were doing we were doing
what we were doing and we're
perfectly willing if one of us was up on
the stage um the other one would raise
your hands like no i think you got that
wrong
and the students could see the the
disagreement in real time
with no animus and this is what um don
tinkle and dick alexander did
and i know it's been tried in various
ways in the news
over over the decades sometimes
successfully some very often not but
i don't even know if anyone is
attempting that at this point so i would
i would like uh you know what do you say
an ideal website you know like
i i would like some some things
that don't just have one person trying
to take you know try and you know go
watch the the democratic convention the
republican convention and report back
um but maybe even you know fairly you
know polarized entrenched people but
good
faith who actually can admit when
they're wrong and who can see the wisdom
of the other side
going at it over ideas that they really
disagree about
yeah it has to be uh i mean the funny
thing is the
iconic example of this was crossfire
and i must say tucker carlson when he
was on
crossfire i found to be an incredibly
troubling human being
right um in his later incarnation i
frequently find
that i've this weird fact of him talking
about things that are traditional
left of center territory like class
warfare he's
very honest about class warfare about
the fact that it's bad for average
americans
um that his class won and he's
frustrated that there's nobody on the
other side properly articulating
the counterpoint so it's almost like
what crossfire didn't quite
manage to be is something he has taken
up doing in
later in life and you know i i think
alone yeah yeah
it's an interesting um it's an
interesting transition
but i do think we need a version of that
it has to not be driven by whatever
crossfire was driven by
and it can't be phony um but
there's real room for something lincoln
douglas debate style where people
with honest disagreements but respect
for each other
tangle yeah and you know this is what
idw was exploring
right and maybe you know not you have
sort of the extremes of like
two hosts that are always the host and
always will be and
you know after a couple of years
probably you know for for many people it
it
that dynamic may start to get stale or
you may start to get entrenched because
that's what people are expecting now
um or always guests which don't
necessarily you know they're trying to
just get
their leg in you know their foot in the
door and so
they won't be take as many risks they
should etc but you know something like a
rotating stable of
16 20 people or something who come to
understand
each of those other 16 or 20 people and
are
you know always rotated in and will have
i'm sure you would end up with you know
i really like you know i really like
being on
stage with those three guys and not
those three and here are the ones that i
don't know as well
um but to at least keep it it would keep
it a little bit more surprising
and would i think um avoid some of the
problems of both of the extremes
yeah um well i'd like to see it happen
yeah
oh boy we've only we've gotten through
so few questions
um there is only racism or lack of
racism
there is no reverse racism or
anti-racism
racism can exist in degrees it is not
dichotomous
so i think i basically agree with that
although it is not dichotomous would
appear to be
contradicted by your initial statement
there's only racism or lack of racism
but i mean i think
no no no i i think i i know what the
point is here that it's a continuum
yeah it's a continuum and it may not
even have a discrete
starting point which is why you're
hanging up on there is only
there is no um where is it
there is only racism or lack of racism
so the lack of a discreet starting point
is a challenge to that
yep um you know where it is we're gonna
have to define some
level below which it's not racism yeah
um
but uh i
i'm gonna push back slightly i actually
think racism
naturally is a term that just simply
stems from a race first view of
well-being
and so i agree to an extent
there is something different when a
powerful group
engages in a race first view
it is different in some way than
when a disempowered group engages in
race first
thinking um so
i think the problem is that is not a
match for racism
right that whatever racism um plus
uh the oppressed condition
is is some other term and it is the
co-opting of the term racism for this
that is so very confusing it doesn't
mean that the addition of the two
characteristics isn't some
unique entity okay
we're going to try to get through a
number of the rest of these um
fairly quickly what is the evolutionary
justification for allergies
given how many grasses and molds i'm
allergic to it seems maladaptive
yeah allergies are maladaptive a lot of
them seems to
stem from the so
the immune system makes different kinds
of antibodies antibodies
are immunoglobulins ig and there are
different classes of them and the ige
system seems to be triggered by
allergens but not
useful against pathogens which makes it
perplexing why would you have an
antibody system
that is reacting to things that aren't
actually hostile to you
now there is strong evidence that
actually this system
was adaptive against things like
worms and that the absence of worms in
modern life has left it idle
and that it is somehow responding to
molecules
that it shouldn't be and so you're
absolutely correct allergies are in and
of themselves
maladaptive why we experience them has
something to do with a mismatch between
us and our modern environment and that
mismatch may be
in whole or in part the absence of the
pathogen to which
those those antibodies are targeted
okay the next two are comments it
doesn't matter what the action or token
is
which is shown by the fact that it's
made up on the spot it is a symbol of
pure power which states we're now in
control and there is nothing you can do
about it
yeah so this to our discussion in the
last hour and that's right
and a second comment from someone else
love and support you both and brett i
hope the unity project works out
eventually we will need it but it's
become clear to me that a firm hand is
needed to deal with the bang of donkeys
trump has my vote we've heard this from
other people
yep yep
i think you should uh i think you should
cool criticism of people wearing masks
outside
some people feel safer with them on even
if they realize the lack of utility and
don't judge others
it can help psychologically yeah i think
this is right i'm
i'm i'm concerned that people
are increasingly going to be so
completely covered that they're not
going to get
any exposure to the sun at all this is
just obviously one of the
drums i'm banging lately but i do agree
i mean i think
i i would rather they not
look with fear and hostility at those of
us who will not wear masks outside
when we understand when what we
believe to be true about the virus now
means that that keeps us safe and that
we are in fact
um doing just fine without masks outside
but
uh but but i hear this yeah i feel
slightly misunderstood
i have no criticism if you want to wear
a mask outside and if you feel
you know you're taking an extra step
what i feel
is a i want to alert people that
you know the fact is you could do
everything in your power
not to encounter any human beings you
could
also wear a full body hazmat
suit right there all sorts of things you
could do that you're not doing so you
are
drawing a line somewhere and my point
to people is a winter is coming as we
keep saying
now is the moment to take advantage of
the fact that you have
the daylight you have uv radiation
giving you double protection outside
and to the extent that you are going to
feel oppressed when winter arrives back
here in the northern hemisphere
this is a moment to drink in as much
contact direct contact with the outside
world as you can
so i you know if somebody feels safer
wearing the masks that's fine but i want
them to know that they have a choice
about where they're drawing the line and
that i
firmly believe you have an obligation to
wear your mask indoors to protect
others even if you don't believe it just
the chances that you're wrong are so
great you have that obligation but the
data itself tells us outside for the
moment at least
is quite safe and you know if you're
standing talking to somebody maybe you
should put your mask up that's probably
right
but if you're just walking along the
chances are minuscule and you might as
well
take the advantage of good weather
and reduce the level of oppression
because you're going to feel the
opposite six months from now
yep this is another comment
interesting starship troopers is on the
army officer reading list this is this
uh highland book i actually read it for
the first time sometime in the last
couple of years
so he says starship troopers is on the
army officer reading list it gives the
closest account to what it feels like in
basic training
interesting gives you insight into how
soldiers are conditioned to not buckle
under pressure
interesting it has also been recommended
to me by dave who made the
knife behind me
what should one do if they feel like
they're in a group with some wolves in
sheep's clothing
and some sheep i spared myself the
struggle session and walked away does
that make me a coward
no but i would certainly if you can
identify who the sheep are and who the
wolves are
you might begin to create spaces that
are safe enough that you can explore
this with the sheep so that they
are at least aware enough that it will
free spaces
wolf free spaces yes
that's what you're wrapping wfs yes um
wolf free spaces are uh very good for
sheep so anyway you might explore it
with them
such that even if they can't hear you
right away at the point the wolves begin
to reveal themselves
they will think back to what you said
and potentially it will trigger
something that's it
lodge something that can that can show
back up in people's memory
are you familiar with the soviet
defector yuri besmanov the current
movement on the far left seems to be
closely following a strategy somewhat
similar to what he outlined for marx's
takeovers of society
do you have thoughts yep i'm familiar a
bit
i've done a little bit of listening
somebody recommended and i on a drive
somewhere was
listening to it um i get something from
it i'm a little concerned that i'm not
exactly sure
enough what is being said in order to i
yes
this is now showing up in uh
in dialogue about this strategy
but i'd like to understand better what
it is people are seeing
at the moment i think the uh alignment
between it and what we are seeing is too
loose to actually have any
useful sense about it okay uh two more
here and then we'll switch to
this hours super chat uh
hydroxychloroquine and zinc combo is not
dangerous
observational studies show it lowers
mortality and severity of covet
why not take it since there are no
downsides and there's a chance of upside
so this question reads to me quite
different depending on whether or not
i imagine that some people would argue
why not just take it to prophylactically
like a multivitamin and
some people and and maybe that's what
you mean here and maybe what you mean is
if you have cobia why not take it i
think that's what i think that's the
implication
i think so too um although i want to
address the first possibility first
which is um again the first possibility
of what is being said here is why not
just take this sort of hydroc
hydroxychloroquine
zinc combo prophylactically um
since there are no downsides and there's
a chance of upside uh
we don't know what downsides there are
uh and
uh unless you actually understand
yourself to
have covet 19 the fact that you're in
zinc
probably you're probably going to have a
hard time overdosing on zinc
but anything that you take in excess has
a chance of
affecting you badly and
hydroxychloroquine
um yes originally it's um boy what
i can't remember what botanical
chloroquine originally oh uh
corner from it's quite oh it's the the
tree uh i can't think what it is at the
moment
yep that'll come to me uh or leaf
um but it's it's synthesized in the lab
with a whole bunch of other stuff
and uh you know for instance we know and
i'm not saying that it's at all what's
going on with hydroxychloroquine but
um one of the big health effects
of the opioid addiction uh in
in the us is that there's a whole lot of
other stuff that comes with the pills
that people are getting the opiates from
and so the fact that tylenol has been
um part of the opiates uh that people
are becoming addicted to
and that tylenol has known liver
toxicity and
causes hearing loss and you know all of
these other things
means that some some by no means all and
probably not the majority but a large
fraction
of the the downstream health effects
of the opioid epidemic is because people
are
getting their opiates through pills that
were produced with
other things in part as a measure to
reduce people's reliance on opiates
so you know it's a it's a vicious circle
um that is causing problems
um because of the other things in the
pills so you know i don't know what else
is in the hydroxychloroquine
or how it's synthesized or even just
what the effects of hydroxychloroquine
long-term on a body are but if you're
talking about the other thing
which is if you have covered 19 does
this
does this cocktail seem to be effective
and
low low risk it does especially if you
catch it early
um it seems like the later you are in
the progression of the disease is the
less likely it is to do any good
um we talked previously about a
situation in which i
briefly thought i might have coveted it
turned out i didn't
um but at that time i certainly
was of the mindset if i wanted to get
hydroxychloroquine could i i think the
answer is it's actually difficult
in oregon to do so and that troubles me
because i do think
um as we've tried to articulate
covet is less deadly in the acute sense
than we thought but it is
more destructive than we thought and so
anything you can do to reduce the
effectiveness of the disease once you
have
contracted it is probably worthwhile
it's probably even worth
taking a significant risk the brain
damage
and the heart damage that seemed to be
regular products of
kovid 19 are serious and so
um i you know i hate this is a political
question i hate that people will take my
answer as political but if i
came down with covet 19 i would be
interested in
sourcing hydroxychloroquine quickly
because that's when it has maximal
effect and i think i would be very
likely to take it
yeah okay okay
i finally know why i like you guys even
though we don't totally agree
politically your movie list is my movie
list including fellini and
gilliam gilliam gilliam yep terry
gilliam
okay uh let's answer
several of the questions that came in
this hour to what extent would you say
you two espouse objectivism allah and
rand
favor individualism to collectivism and
feel these philosophies are missing from
the american conversation
i would say not at all in the randian
sense but there is
you know we've tried to lay this out a
little bit
i think the the thing is society
should endeavor to deliver a fair
structure in which people can take
personal responsibility and it has the
maximum
possible effect in other words you want
as much of this shunted over to personal
responsibility landscape as you can
but a fair landscape in which people's
personal responsibility
functions best is desirable and so i
feel like
um the problem with the the
ann randian view of the universe is it
just
focuses entirely on one side of a
two-sided truth
and is very unsatisfying in that regard
but
that said the world i want to see is one
in which personal responsibility works
yeah is neanderthal
mitochondrial dna no longer present in
current humans
why did sapiens moms supported by
sapiens culture survive better than
neanderthal moms and were neanderthal
moms never integrated into sapiens
culture
oh wow um interesting i don't
i've never i don't know the answer
i've never thought to ask the question
before and
i have not i know that i have not seen
any papers that specifically mentioned
neanderthal mitochondrial dna
um the the just super basic uh
genetic molecular biology underlying the
question is that mitochondrial dna
because it is in the egg and not in the
sperm
can be tracked entirely through the
maternal line and so we would expect a
senior to all
mitochondrial dna in any descendants of
neanderthals
of neanderthal females and if there are
no neanderthal females
in our descendants of course we know
that europeans have a fair bit of
uh not a fair bit some neanderthal
in us um does that mean that it's
entirely from the mail line
um i don't think so and i think this
actually treads very close to
a question from our last live stream
that we ultimately
uh chased down to bedrock i thought yeah
yeah yeah
i think you're right actually and so
basically the idea is a
you you know you don't see it similarly
no actually it's not going to be the
same so well and we should we should
clarify the question from last time was
about uh the y chromosome and do all the
male descendants of say genghis khan
have his y
chromosome no unless it's an
uninterrupted male line
right right because the daughter of
um the daughter of genghis khan would
have two x chromosomes and her
son would still be a male descendant of
genghis khan but would not have his y
chromosome
whereas the son son son son son of
genghis
khan would have his y chromosome because
there was only one place one y
to be transferred compared to
um the egg is present
well it's okay maybe i think it may be
maybe it's the
same so the son
of a neanderthal mother
no yeah the son of a neanderthal mother
could have a daughter who uh
would have a daughter who does not have
neanderthal mitochondrial dna
even though he is neanderthal well the
son of a neanderthal mother who has a
homo sapiens father
yep um actually that does that part
doesn't matter
if he is mayor is he is having sex with
uh sapiens female then
their son would or their daughter
my god their daughter would have sapiens
mitochondrial dna
um so that explains
why we don't inherently that doesn't
inherently mean that there are no
maternal maternal ancestors
in the neanderthal line but it is
interesting isn't it that
at least i have not heard any mention of
mitochondrial
dna from the neanderthal line
no i mean i think this i think this
seems straightforward
because uh a a tiny selective
advantage of sapiens mitochondria would
be expected in the scenario that we just
painted why um because the point is
um that selective advantage
what you have is a decoupling of the
genomic dna from the mitochondrial dna
and a slight advantage of sapiens
mitochondria
could account for the the total absence
of
mitochondrial winners that would behave
oh absolutely could i just ask you why
you expect a selective advantage
i don't but the fact that you don't find
these other mitochondria
all it takes the only assumption it
takes is a is a tiny selective advantage
of sapience mitochondrial dna
right over neanderthal so i was just
asking you what what you think that
might be but it actually isn't necessary
for
just proof of concept that something
simple could result in this i also think
that a just a simple law
of large numbers issue could be
sufficient in this case
that um the question of an
unbroken female line
um might be very unlikely um
and so you know i could imagine
hybrid advantage to sapiens neanderthal
hybrids that would account for certain
uh
bits of genome being transmitted through
time yeah i can imagine a
neutral comparison between the
mitochondria of
neanderthals and sapiens resulting in
the loss of the neanderthal dna for no
selective reason
just because it would have been small in
percentage and
i could also imagine a small advantage
of
mitochondrial dna from sapiens driving
out yeah
the other so um i guess the point is i
don't think this is all that's
surprising because there are multiple
routes that you would get there
okay uh next question we're gonna do a
few more
and go over a little bit since we took a
long time on the early questions
uh we have 21 plus senses ryan argues
but only test if the main five are
calibrated properly could some people be
sensing reality in dramatically
different ways than others
what are the adaptive advantages and
trade-offs well i'd
i'd love to see the reference on 21 plus
senses
but certainly uh we have uh
we have more than the five that are
usually talked about
um including several different you know
basically touch needs to be
um dis dis
disaggregated disaggregated into several
into pressure
into temperature into um
[Music]
at least one more i can't quite movement
um
and pain yeah and um and you know there
and there are senses
that we don't seem to have but other
organisms do and so is it possible that
we have
any latent uh for instance
magnetoreception or electroreception
or foam or nasal sense
what you see when you know when when a
horse or your cat
seems to smell something on the wind but
opens their mouth a little bit
um that's not actually smelling it's a
sort of a it's a chemical sense like
smell and taste but it's taking in
larger odorant molecules than smell can
take
can can assess and supposedly our
vomeronasal organ is
is turned off it's you know it's not
hooked up um but
it's it's a question so you know there
are definitely other senses that we have
that that are possible and there are
ways to disaggregate the senses that we
do know we have
in ways that might be more useful even
like you know vision you know color
vision versus black and white
lines versus pattern these are all um
you know interesting and useful ways i
think to actually talk about the senses
one jacobson's organ which is the
vomeronasal organ
in people uh i believe it passes the
adaptive test
if it was rapidly shrinking that would
be a different question but if it is
persistent
i don't think it is size then it passes
the adaptive test and that means that
like the appendix we will likely
discover that it is hooked up to
something or is another some other way
useful
let's just um let me just add a little
bit in there i actually don't remember
the size of it
in or maybe i never knew in all the
other primates
but one thing we see with the origin of
primates so
mammals our mammal history has a strong
move
towards smell as one of the dominant
senses
that is going on in mammals and we see
the primitively
smell part of the brain becomes actually
the cerebral cortex
in in us and so that's the part that
gets really big and then
and so you have you know well over 100
million years
maybe over well over 200 million years
of um basically smell
forward evolution in mammals and then
you get to
the origin of primates and smell begins
to take a backseat to
vision and you see basically the you
know the visual cortex is getting bigger
you have eyes
um moving from you know more more on the
side of the head to
more more binoculars so that you can end
up getting uh depth of field
and um you know the bigger relative
to the face so primates in general are
becoming more vision focused
but it has been a sort of a pat answer
of course and i'm not telling you
anything that you don't know um but
there's been a pat ads that well like oh
well premise just don't smell well
and of course we are we are a primate
and we smell even less well than
everyone else because we are so
vision driven and that's that's not
actually how it works right
you're saying that wrong primates don't
smell good and this is
a misapprehension especially yes
well um you are about to tell me
something
that i don't know i hope okay um how
far back is the vomeronasal organ
supposedly unhooked
oh so i don't i don't know uh i
my right so
are there i'm trying to i'm trying to
think as i'm just filling space with
words here are there any
primates that was the dog
not me thinking um are there any primate
species
that are understood to have active and
functioning foam or nasal organs
i can't think of any so what that says
then is that this is a slam
dunk that's an
or at least has until very recently in
our line because we're talking about
many millions of years of it persisting
with no value which makes no sense of
course
so take that as a challenge um here's
the other thing
what happened you were talking about
vomeronasal organs this was the
perfect opportunity for you to invoke
lizards which you have been talking
about doing and you just like
blew right by if i'm done i'm done with
lizards what happened
i'm done okay well final thing
21 senses i'm not sure what that refers
to i'd love to know i know that there
are 16 different kinds of awesome and i
imagine that there would be a sense for
each of them 21 though seems a stretch
but i'd love to know
maybe there's 16 kinds of awesome plus
the five uh 16 other kinds of senses
plus the main five senses that he's
named here so
16 plus five there you go you've got the
one two three four five senses working
overtime and with that we'll move on to
the next question we will
in one of oh this is from bill maher
apparently um
wow in one of uh in one of jordan
peterson's lectures
he lists off careers and the iq needed
to succeed in those fields
i find this discouraging can a person
with an average iq succeed in complex
fields
can hard work compensate for being
average thank you
um i'd like to see i'd like to see that
lecture i'll bet he does
a more nuanced i bet he has a more
nuanced take than that suggests
yep um people take iq
to mean heritable and they take
heritable to mean hardwired by the
genome and it doesn't mean these things
here's the thing
expose your kids to stuff
that enhances their ability to calculate
right i don't mean calculating the
narrow mathematical sense though that
stuff is quite good
but the basic point is iq
is amenable to intervention as much as
the literature
cast doubt on that in some context but
um
i just don't think this means what we
think it means are there ways to
compensate
yes the earlier the intervention the
more likely it is
to succeed um and the question really is
can you find
puzzles that exercise the relevant
circuitry in a useful and
self-augmenting way
okay good if conscience
is an adaptation does that mean that our
life choices that go against our evolved
nature even detrimentally are as well
for instance modern diets and excessive
internet use i don't get this question
yet do you
not not quite i think um
i think basically if you have i think
the question is
if the ability to make choice is an
adaptation does that mean that every
choice that you make is therefore
adaptive
and and no the answer is is no
well the i think the this surface is a
really important
thing though which is that you can have
two adaptations
in opposition this this is the same
thing oh this is also true
yeah we're talking about with uh
foreskin and circumcision
yeah right foreskin is a is a
morphological adaptation circumcision is
a cultural adaptation
presumably they are responsive to
different environments in which
different
top values are reflected
so what the person is getting at
is basically and you should frequently
expect this to be
the hierarchy that a cultural mechanism
will interrupt a deeper adaptive
mechanism
right so forbidding yourself access to
something for some reason
is two things in opposition and i think
if i'm reading the question yes um
modern-day
life choices that go against our evolved
nature as well
yes totally um if you
are prone to seek sugar because sugar
was so scarce in your ancestral
environment that
you were in no danger of toxifying
yourself with it and any amount you
could get was a win
and now you're forbidding yourself sugar
because you're making yourself sick or
fat with it
that is your ability to detect a pattern
which is adaptive
overriding and more basic pattern which
is
but the metal level might be adapted but
that doesn't mean that all the choices
are
no no there's not going to be
this is all in there does that mean that
our life choices that go against our
evolved nature are as well
okay then the ambiguities in the
question
the problem is if you say all
then the answer is no if you say
some then the answer is many are but not
all
the woke youtube channel was useful last
night in wisconsin
it's multiple knives live cams of all
protests and quotes
by 1am it looked like a scene from
terminator with all the burning cars and
buildings if that's a protest i never
want to see a riot
yeah i don't know this channel but
that's a that's a useful uh
i saw many of the videos though yeah
there is
no way we are going to get out of this
if we don't find some way to arrest that
impulse yeah uh let's do
three more the last of which is a
comment
i have recently encountered a flat
earther at my workplace who was actively
trying to convert and brainwash younger
more impressionable staff members
i find it hard to address this
individual without losing my temper do
you have advice
i assume here that flat earther is
metaphorical although we know that there
are actually some flat earthers out
there
um no no i think this is literal
well i think it's more important in the
moment to answer this as if it's
uh uh metaphorical but you want you want
to do it
literally if it's literal then
time zones are the key to tormenting
this person into seeing the light
um if it's metaphorical it's more
difficult yeah
um so what is it
what do you think we're being asked
we're being
asked about uh the
the creeping ideology that is taking
over
about that i mean i don't know i
wouldn't have exactly put it
in flat earther terms but it's
it's everything we've been talking about
it's it's it's these people who have
adopted
the woke thinking
um i'm i mean i may be wrong
in which case you know we've talked
about this you know it's a problem
because it's the
game theory and the fear of being
stigmatized that drives people and so
you know it's going to be very hard to
create
enough safety that people can actually
see it i guess maybe i would ask
if this is really about that woke
ideology i would ask
um to hear what system it is that they
envision
and how is it going to function because
yeah it doesn't seem to answer any of
those questions
you know actually it might if this
really is a flat earther um like i've
never met one in real life as far as i
know
it's that it strikes me as a unicornish
um
it might be i mean it's your workplace
and so you have to be careful but it
might be
really useful to try to develop tools
that could also be deployed against
the the kind of woke mob but because
in the case of flat earth there is
you're simply right and he's simply
wrong and there's
there's just no end of evidence in
support of your position
and no end of evidence against his i
presume
maybe wrong maybe it's a her um so it
seems like you could
consider all the evidence and you know
try just
try in a number of different ways to
en engage you know engage your
co-workers
you know see if you see if you put a
good piece of evidence in the heads of a
couple of your co-workers if it comes
back to you through someone else's mouth
um you know it seems like an interesting
way to see
how such thinking can spread and how you
might arrest it
in what is in one way as high stakes as
it gets because someone who actually
believes that the earth is flat
can presumably not be reasoned with on
any number of subjects
but another way the stakes are
incredibly low because what actually
does a totally ludicrous belief in a
flat earth how will that manifest in
such a way that
anyone is less safe as a result of you
know sharing a
refrigerator with them all right
okay do you have thoughts about the
unfortunate connotations of light as
good
and dark as evil see for instance
biden's dnc speech
as misapplied to skin color what other
simplistic associations have we not
shaken off evolutionarily
yeah my thought is we all need to just
grow up
and that you can go around policing
these
little things but i don't see that as
uh it's not significant
right it's significant if you imbue it
with power yeah even if it has a
racist history if we all just understand
that this is
you know it's like gender in
romance languages the fact that the
table is female
is really not troubling yeah right you
could take it as troubling but it just
isn't and you know see my earlier
comment about
the origin of primates which is probably
more than 100 million years ago
saw our ancestors moving towards a
vision
vision forward life and
that meant becoming less nocturnal and
more diurnal and relying on
photons and being able to see things
literally and of course
our english like every language is
filled with metaphor and most of the
metaphors are actually hiding
um like almost every sentence that we
use even ones that we think are very
very straightforward are filled with
metaphor and so
of course we have come to associate
light with goodness and
dark with with places where things can
hide because literally things can hide
when you cannot see them
the unfortunate coincidence
that the group of people who have been
most frequently uh who have most
frequently suffered
uh racism have darker skin than those
who have most frequently been the ones
enforcing that racism is actually just
a coincidence it's just not related in
any way
like there's there's just nothing there
that makes that
a correlation and so we have all these
metaphors in the english language as a
result of us being diurnal
and and and vision um focused
and then we also have melanin as an
adaptation to living near the equator
and add to that as sort of a guns germs
and steel style argument around
which peoples uh were most likely to be
taken advantage of and it's just not the
same thing
and so yeah you can map those on
and it's really unfortunate because
there's no mapping that should be
happening there
what other simplistic associations have
we not shaken off i'm sure there's many
many and we should come back to that
question but at the moment i'm not
thinking of them yep and finally
just a comment grateful for your podcast
you model so much decency patriotism a
great personal and professional
relationship and
intellectual fun thank you diana all
right
thank you all right
so that's it for episode 41. uh i
believe
we will be back on saturday we keep on
saying this we really are going to drop
to somewhat less frequent in fact we
won't be back a week from now
i think but we'll be back on saturday
for episode 42.
um and immediately following that will
be
the next day will be our private q a
that's available to people who
subscribe to my patreon and you can look
at either of our patreons go to either
our patreons
and become patrons to access the private
discord server
and unity will be having a campfire
tomorrow
wednesday i've forgotten whether we
moved the time so i'm not going to say a
time
check out our channel and you will find
out that 4 p.m
pacific time a voice said to me
4 p.m pacific time so anyway that should
be great tune in to that
and oh uh we've released the brendan
o'neal episode of dark horse that is now
available on the channel you can go
check that out and we will see you next
time
in the meantime be well
[Music]
you